[Music]
um
so
which one do i need to play first here
frozen
uh
i would go with the the the one about
his vision first i guess
the secrets of no no no no no that was
the last one for sure okay so this one
or this one
either either or okay because one is a
house tour the other one is him
basically describe yeah
105
000 square foot property
is valued at half a billion dollars
[Music]
nobody's ever been allowed to release a
video tour of the property okay now with
this one it's better if you just skip
through because it has like little
little sections for the room epic of
epic videos
we are at
the largest house in the urban world
when i say the largest it is a hundred
and five thousand square feet it is
called the why is michael kane that
wearing a wig
one and what gets better than that she
was only 15 years old we are with the
one the one and only
niall who is the visionary behind this
he built this and he is just
an incredible guy and he's going to show
us around this house i hate him robin
leech over here this house is valued at
nighttime
all along
that no cameras don't look at his shoes
by the way
is that correct that's right so this is
the thing
let's do it let me show you guys
think that british guys shirt was
oh that's the part that that's probably
the two thousand dollar shirt they have
at dan flash's that's pretty cool
that that opens into itself check that
out what the [ __ ] is that
what
like a statue or something biometric we
have the latest technology in the house
okay whoa
guys i have never been in this house
before this is the thing i've never been
in any house before i live in a harvard
first time walking through the door adam
has never been in i live in what j.r.r
tolkien calls a shire are you looking at
his cool diamond earring
i hate being in the shower
hello fellow youths
you know what to say
let me show you let me show you over
here so we'll come and go this way this
is a all a lot of the artwork we have
the sculpture done original for this
house this artwork here is from michael
phelps it's called unity and it was made
for the house
artwork by who
michael phelps the swimmer
yes hold on hold on hold on
now this opens up for first off no
you're right
first off look at his shoes i just saw
them i know what frozen meant guys look
at this fucker's shoes dude
[ __ ]
leading me you know what to do
[ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is up with this guy's shoes
oh my god look at this
look at those shoes okay it's not the
same michael phelps oh good okay thank
god
the swimmer is an artist i mean he
smokes weed
oh [ __ ]
hmm
dude look at those [ __ ] shoes man you
think you got it at santa right
now if you'll excuse me i need to go
make cookies in a tree
[Laughter]
uh
this dude's been trying to show the [ __ ]
mansion forever i know that's the whole
point of this we we're building we're
building it turns 360 degrees
this foyer because there's so many
seating areas in the house this foyer is
playing
it's like an art gallery
when you first enter this
[Laughter]
let me show you over here so we have um
a two-story office with an office
balcony i have to ask you why would you
need a two-story office question do you
get lost
oh yeah the art's great the art
the arts also from dan flashes
by the way pasty um
he has many art galleries in this house
this house is dan flashes and i sell the
shirts in the basement i don't even feel
big anymore because i've done it oh is
this shops at the creeks
but you know it's i know it is
one thing you guys need to know 10 years
in the making right 10 years december
2012 was when i first
bought this land 10 years to build this
gaudy place and um
and we've been pushing ever since was he
pinching
hold on i'm going to see something cause
i think i caught something here ten
years royce a lot of scamming and
running and scamming and running
let me see something
pushing ever since and this this office
is
one thing you guys need to know 10 years
in the making right 10 years december
2012 was when i
why is he grabbing his titty
wait dude play go back out a few frames
yeah
he's not scratching or something
oh no he is grabbing it
he's getting off
yeah and i thought of the thought of his
house oh my god dude he's [ __ ] tits
oh well what's he pinching
his nipple
and scratching his tin the church
and this this office oh you know what he
was doing he was he was hardening his
fabric to air it i thought he was
harding his nips so they looked better
in his shirt
surrounded by water so we have little
moats and we have a total of seven water
features and swimming okay so
pay attention to how many water features
he has through the house by the way
california has a water problem
oh my god you're right
but this office you'll see every single
wall in this office touches water so
it's like it's floating
this is just incredible look at the
height of this i i'm six foot two no
you're not yeah did i me
did i mention that this house has a moat
oh yeah what is the moat supposed to
keep out i'm sorry what
all right let's move to another room in
the house let's move to the formal
living room okay oh my god this is
insane is this not the four seasons
i feel like i'm in the future
oh my word this is the beauty dan
bilzerian's brain the house yes
still you know that the thing that is
crazy about this house there's so many
crazy beautiful things but one of them
is
i have a backyard with a view of the
entire la basin and the ocean
and one acre of usable space which does
not happen anywhere boys here's to
mudslides eh cheers
it's just crazy oh by the way all you
notice how everything's open
everything's activated
so the walls come up
now what would it happen if i don't know
where if a giant power outage were to
happen
i don't look man this this level of of
of
what is this the artwork
yeah milan's wife glasses just getting
divorced unfortunately it was a
whirlwind relationship i met her during
coven and you got divorced work out yeah
i wonder why it will still at the end i
don't know but this is a charity that we
have called wings of angels and this is
going to help children in third world
countries
through the arts because she is a
well-known actress and singer in
argentina and she she came from a very
tough life in cordoba and she wants to
be part of the
gonna help third world children royce
what the [ __ ]
you're gonna see
you're gonna see a pattern everything in
this house supposedly will help change
the world okay
frozen this guy is firefest the human
yes
all right
what the [ __ ] i just going around the
house we kind of get a good you know lay
of the yeah all the kids is that you
trying to say no no no no
this is the first kitchen
is never going to be used yes
so it's one of seven kitchens that won't
be touched
you couldn't even imagine this right i
could not imagine i mean look at that
just look at this pool number one of
five of the houses
percentage-wise that we're looking we're
gonna shoot a porn here and we're gonna
shoot a porn here and we're gonna shoot
a porn
is there an overhead shot of the house
like from
a helicopter uh if you go to the end
yeah
i think
or is that the beginning
one of the two
oh my god
there ew
[Music]
what the [ __ ] man
also how was even like you think in a
place like this like how was he even
able to get this land you know
you think it would have been snatched up
and developed
well he's he's also a he's also a real
estate guy so
that's how he made his money
why does this
by the way how do you think
yeah
it looks like the boat level the
in double in goldeneye uh double 07.
on n64 [ __ ] okay so when you when you
look at this right i think
how do i
how do i make my money back because also
i forgot to tell you this also has a
nightclub
oh good
um how do you think you would make your
money back with this house throw parties
and charge film pornography
uh yeah film pornos
okay well his idea is basically to well
if this in the next video will yeah
i have it in uh
this video
yes here's his idea to make money you
ready if you go a little bit back yeah
right around here yeah all right here we
go
can i put myself down for a front row
seat
a little bit more back here and they'll
be 35 okay
leading up to the pay-per-view event
will be my show so hold on i'm just
going to start from the beginning
yeah
wait this
i think in the history of anybody's
channel um i'm sure you all agree the
best house ever
and nile is with me today because i'm
gonna talk to him and uh basically he
said a few things it's the biggest house
i've ever seen
but best no it's not the best how b a
lot of these people think because it's
really big right that that makes it the
best that's not true
i'd rather have a [ __ ] corvette than
a humvee
in
the house tour that spanked my curiosity
and uh who better to explain it than
nile
you said
in the last bro he looks like the steep
uchemi meme
right like my fellow hello my fellow
kids like
just like that look at him looks like
every
no he looks like every 1970s
british tv presenter that got put away
for diddling yeah dude he's so [ __ ]
weird video i asked you what is the best
part about this house in fact i think it
was adam even that asked you that
question
and you said
something like
it keeps me away from the jews
i was talking to my friend elmo and he
was
what did you mean tell everybody
well i think that
i have something very very exciting and
i believe that yeah a coke problem
i don't have this by chance i believe
that i was always meant to be able to
create this house when we first
what a [ __ ] oh
what a pretentious [ __ ] right
what a jeff [ __ ] you
tried to pull a permit for this house
the plan checker made a mistake and
approved it for larger than it should be
in the beginning and then they changed
all the rules making it absolutely
impossible to build this house again
really really the one is fitting for
this and the house is called the one bel
air and my show is called the one and
between those two i think that we have
the ability to really change the world
in a very positive way with the house
are you gonna let inner city youth live
in it
i mean
he this guy thinks he's gonna change the
world
with a gaudy house
you know what you know what niall okay
i'll give you this all right you want to
change the world with that house walk
over to the nearest load-bearing beam
and kick it out you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
[Music]
kick it out
when you say change the world in a
positive way how does this house
change the world i i i mean
carbon footprint is huge
the if you look up in the sky the ozone
is decaying over just my home
i will explain so
because of covet
here we go
all of the venues around the world have
been either shut down they're open in
florida or dramatically altered not in
florida there is nowhere in the world
really where you can go
for
a vineyard like you used to have florida
like a big boxing match
the first ufc fight after covert was in
florida
for the academy awards
we don't want them here they're not
welcome so you could keep the academy
awards go have it in a [ __ ] sabaro in
[ __ ] l.a or the graham not actually
i'd watch that yeah so would i but they
don't shut it down it's an active
sapporo you know what i mean there's
people ordering pizza and lasagna
meryl streep's thinking the academy
somebody's like yo move [ __ ] i need my
garlic sauce yeah yeah hey the red
pepper flakes over here
pushed by her or anything else that
required a large crowd to gather at
staples center or mgm or caesar's palace
or any of these other places
but we have it now
because this house
has the ability
to turn into a robot that's right the
house is also a transformer
to hold 900 people
in a safe coveted environment
and
what so your business plan was to sell
stuff for a virus that's obviously not
going to be around forever right like
what happens when the covert
restrictions go away then what
happens when we by the way the staple
set i know this video is probably what a
year ago right the staples center is now
open and they are having concerts at it
we we wanted to have a say uh we wanted
to have a place where 900 people could
be safe from covid what about fentanyl
overdoses oh no kovid only kovacs okay
oh
being creative by the way uh lee didn't
mean that
the thing you wanted passing yes
yes
i don't know
it's such a stupid gimmick but i love it
they're so long
yeah but yeah back there
hold on i'm not done yet
okay i'm johnny longshu
this is a show
that is a show that everyone will want
to watch and identify with because it
stars me i live in the house and i live
in the house with people that i love
and
we do crazy things and have crazy
parties you have planks you have prank
wars is there a point by the way he's
gonna change the world by having crazy
parties in his house that probably have
a lot of cocaine yeah you're right
that's gonna change the world that's
every [ __ ] home in [ __ ] bel air
you idiot
but we also
help
the world if sitting at home and doing
drugs changes the world me and jj are
philanthropists
they should be building they should be
building statues of you guys yeah jj
where's our statue
help
the world in so many different ways and
one of those ways we're doing it is
we are creating gigantic
boxing matches
right in the glass
so his plan to save the world is to have
boxing matches on his front lawn
our entitled tyler durden
dumb [ __ ]
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't know why miss this guy broke me
he's so stupid
we're gonna put we're gonna put buttons
on the fists of the fighters and every
time a punch connects it donates 15
to a charitable cause
right in the grass with the world
championship boxers that you could ever
imagine like name some
wait wait why did he
why didn't he say with the world
championship he went world championship
boxers
and concerts and anything that you could
imagine that has a blind
blind melons going to be playing there a
pay-per-view event
leading up to the pay-per-view event
will be my show so the it'll be my one
man show
the talent will come through the lands
will be here and we will interact
the weigh-ins
i don't know what
oh weigh-ins like wait
but the weigh-ins are gonna be marlin
wayne's is gonna be doing the weigh-ins
in a ryan's vans all of the
entertainment that lead to the
pay-per-view platform but the
pay-per-view platform will be
either a showtime or our own
pay-per-view platform that will rain
money down and with that i am going to
have a very very successful show and i'm
going to have wow he really is very
hopeful for this home huh
what happened
i'm sorry frozen what happened so
he had this grand idea right of course
yeah the boxing matches now now this
this grand idea costs money yes yes most
things do
uh
he he basically exhausted all his
personal money and did he get
loans right of course of course that
happened now
he he he could not pay back these loans
in time right uh so the house of the
bank
yes the bank took it so now bank of
america owns this home okay
now the bank is now trying to auction
off this house and nobody wants to buy
it because it's how much are they
selling it for
i
don't remember yeah i'm just curious
because
he said he would he spent half a billion
is that what he said or that's what it's
valued at
hey frozen i guess this he should have
called the house the nun
the nun
they used to have where you have energy
apparently
165 million
oh no that's a dwarf in the amount of
what it's worth that's hilarious
and you have atmosphere and that's what
we're going to but even if you're a
celebrity right and you want to be gaudy
and buy this house right like
just maintaining it seems like it would
be a nightmare right
to do exactly right here starting the
next week
frozen so this house didn't work out but
he read the secret
oh yeah he did put it out in the
universe did they know that now he said
that about that uh this is his plan to
get back the house
oh wow there's more what's his plan
what's this also gives a back story of
how he got this house okay this is the
plan okay
all right
what what what is
this same video another video
the the the secret one the secret guy
yeah
this guy exists
oh yeah he's he's he's the world's
biggest dummy welcome to the one secrets
where oh my god he is damned
oh my god the secrets that were worth
billions of dollars
i'm sure once you see this
you will understand by the way guys guys
i know what somebody on coke looks like
this guy
in my opinion
looks like he has a cocaine problem hey
royce yeah
can you put the hat on
yes yeah
hold on nice
sweet choker bro
sick choker
can you make it tighter
only when i need to come bro do we put
the the glasses or the the the fighters
will be aligned with my thinking
hopefully there's someone out there that
is going to want to walk hand in hand
with me into the stratosphere however
this house will go into auction you can
just fly yourself into the [ __ ]
to the highest bidder no doubt about
that yeah that's how that's how it works
if you sold it to the lowest bidder
then you're a bad businessman and walks
into the stratosphere with me
don't wait for it he's looking for a
hero
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god he is firefest the person he
really is
livestock
why did he buy so much stock footage
he's broke
in the urban world
the one
my name is nyle miami okay notice that
it looks like he's in a different
country
my mother
laurie naomi worked as a special ed oh
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
special ed teacher single mom
i grew up with my mom
and my younger sister delisha
then in 2001 my mom was a special ed
teacher that's why she always talked to
us like we were [ __ ] i received word
that my mother
was violently
murdered
what is using your mom's death for pity
yeah what does this have to do with the
house man
so i told myself that i would build this
huge party venue where my friends could
do coke and have boxing matches in her
honor
you don't understand she's buried in the
walls and she has the treasure map is in
her mouth and he needs it
was a horrible turning into an american
dad episode dude difficult thing to deal
with but it made me work hey it's indian
superman carter
house after house remodel after remodel
i built a lot of like weight loss right
myself i started with nothing
yes frozen
weight loss it's a lot of weight loss
probably grams and grams of weight loss
snorted lines
weight loss before this video i fought
and i fought every day
getting to where i am now
i partnered with paul mclean who was an
unknown why do all of his how why do all
of the homes that he designs look like
when a kid puts in the infinite money
cheat on the sims yes
so by the way paul mclean is john
mcclane's brother who became an
architect
who was an unknown architect together
we designed several homes including the
most iconic home as you know now the one
bel air
to create the large flat three acre pad
frozen is he in the philippines
i don't know i had to remember i wanted
to say costa rica yards of dirt that
could never be done today
to create the lawns and to create the
public areas we had to
create a basement that was 50 000 square
feet to support the upper
levels it was a giant feat and a
magnitude of something that i never
should have done you never ever should
have done
walls of glass where you could see the
people swimming it has a 4 000 square
foot guest where's the selling point
with the creation
of the nightclub
god the [ __ ] it was virtually stated
that after only three events the value
of that business would be three hold on
hold on hold on go back to this go back
to the shot of the people at the party
oh my god
i mean the people of the green screen
yeah yeah but i wanted to see if they
want to see if they reused i want to see
if the same woman is in like other shots
there's only three of them like the
value of that business oh my god yes the
woman in the red dress and the oh my god
three to four billion dollars
eight years ago i got a call from my
friend i sold the house to and he told
me niall get up you are going to meet
elon musk in one hour
okay i think you skipped a little bit
but okay so before this he says
uh while he was making doing the house
right
uh
he had an offer
from
the saudi princes
to
uh for eight million eight million okay
to rent out the place right okay
he refuses because he came up with the
idea of the boxing matches so he could
have he could have unloaded this
yes and he didn't
no god and his girlfriend but i had no
idea
that all of those years ago
would create an idea
that is without any doubt worth billions
and billions and billions of dollars
digital currency
that could be backed by actual real
estate assets
i'm telling you chris
just attracts scumbags with his own [ __ ]
coin
a digi backed by real estate
frozen stop laughing like no other in
history imagine taking that digital coin
and breaking it up
i swear to god frozen if it's called one
i'm going to lose my [ __ ] goddamn
frozen frozen stuff
frozen is they call one coin
for all that frozen you gotta keep
rolling pieces
and each piece represents a token
you
are going to be able to give the world
a chance to be part of history
a part of a legacy
a part of the largest house in the urban
world a part of the one bel air once the
tokens are created
and traded it would transfer the value
of the house to the coin
making this the first ever asset-backed
coin
by a one-of-a-kind piece of real estate
and never again will this ever
be able to be done i invite all people
to remember my story the decade it took
to accomplish it the world-changing
ideas that i talked about and remember
unlike the mona lisa you have
hundreds of things that you could do
with so he thinks this this this [ __ ]
gaudy [ __ ] overpriced house
is more important to society
than
the mona [ __ ] lisa
so does everyone that own this so
everyone that owns a coin owns a pro
owns like a pc's house yes
so i could just buy like the most small
fraction of the coin and then just kick
in the door and be like yes my house and
go to your room yeah
yeah cool okay
the one from weddings to building
businesses to unveiling new products
to world
changing pay-per-view events
hold on
look at that to creating your own
pay-per-view platform to nfts and to
never somebody pointed out earlier he's
just saying buzzwords crypto
coins nft elon musk elon musk
or yeah
by the way he said elon musk wanted to
meet with me with an hour but he never
said that he actually met you one month
no no no here's the thing rice
this is he he didn't meet elon musk
he watched a video of elon musk talking
about crypto
because notice he explains what crypto
is but he never he also mentions uh nfts
but he never really
goes into depth about anything real
estate asset in a digital
courtesy remember the billions
guys guys i'll be paying i'll be paying
you guys now exclusively with one coins
okay
that's the that's the official currency
of day wave because i think we all
should own a piece of this house what do
you say guys
this is my second time watching it and
i'm still dying why is there a rabbit on
it
because you know the white rabbit
you gotta follow down the rabbit hole
dollars this will generate overnight the
one why is there a rabbit on the coin
because we always be [ __ ]
we always be [ __ ] boys
ten years of my life
dedication i'm gonna start a day coin
okay day wave coin
where everybody owns everybody owns a
piece of one of jj's peony babies
we'll call it the day queen
oh you jimmy poor jj doesn't feel good
oh [ __ ]
okay catered
10 years to prove that this was 10 years
a house
this was an unbelievable over half a
billion
the one is really the one billy gunn
he's an early investor the one
hey guys i hope this made
me laugh yeah yes it did sir
me angry yes
me [ __ ] furious and me have no faith
in this world anymore yeah we're all
talking we're all talking like the whole
be mad be angry